good evening ladies and gentlemen sorry
about that we had a bit of a problem
with my microphone but we are now live
uh could you turn your
just mute in this option
so we're getting some feedback from a
laptop to my left let's try again shall
we so good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's planning committee meeting
my name is peter richards i will be
chairing tonight's meeting
a few housekeeping things start with by
may uh first of all we're not expecting
a fire alarm so if one does go off
please follow us out of the building and
we will meet in the car park opposite so
we can check everyone is safe and out of
the building um telephones if you could
please turn your phones off that would
be preferable if you need to keep them
on that's fine but please keep them on
silent i don't mind people using their
phones provided it doesn't interfere
with the process of this meeting
the meeting itself is a meeting in
public it is not a public meeting so
only those that have registered to speak
will be permitted to do so i will call
you forward at the appropriate time and
if you grab a seat any one of the three
desks in front of you that would be
great um once you have finished speaking
if you could please answer back your
hands and put an anti back wipe across
the desk that would be greatly
appreciated um we are being live
streamed and uh we are being recorded as
well for uh for future uh display on on
youtube so just please be aware of that
let me introduce our officers if i may
say to my immediate right we have liz
javolska who is from committee services
to my immediate left we have mason nash
who is our solicitor and in no
particular order our planning officers
are sarah mcpherson joe brooke stuart
flaherty and david jeffrey david is our
planning manager david you have a
statement to make
thank you chair yes my name is david
jeffrey i am the planning manager for
tonight's meeting
my role is to provide impartial advice
to clarify any planning issues that
arise and to assist members decision
taking i am bound by the royal town
planning institute's code of
professional conduct and planning
committee members are not bound by
advice from officers or by their
recommendations thank you chair
thank you very much right let's get into
the meeting proper so first of all
apologies for absence please
so our apologies we have had from
councillor curtis councillor eden the
council of foreman and councillor mills
members do we have any disclosures of
interest if i may i'm going to kick off
to start with we have had so today we
had a site visit for um the first
application which is seven benson road
uh we all uh all those in uh attendance
myself cancer hendra surfing and
councillor jennings were given uh this
uh we also i believe have all received
it by email um could have just a quick
nod yes everyone confirms overseas by
email um we did also have a verbal um
communication from a lady called
verading
who has highlighted some of the concerns
that she has they are similar to or the
same as ones that are within
uh the report that is in front of you
councillor jennings
thanks gentlemen um item six i'm the
ward member i've made no comments and
i'll approach
this application with an open mind and
participate in the debate
lovely thank you very much any other
disclosures counselor adam
um just on
the first application um
i'm a friend of the
the agent for the the application but i
come to it with open mind i don't think
it's going to impact
impact me
if you're comfortable that's fine thank
you um
no other disclosures members before we
move on to the minutes um so the next
item is minutes so can i have a share of
hands for those that are happy with the
minutes that i sign them after the
meeting
that looks pretty much unanimous
i don't suppose it will be too dramatic
um but on page 14
top item
thereafter by six votes to four
votes in favor
adds up to ten there were only eight
members present
but just in case it is picked up at any
future point for any reason
understood we will make an amendment um
and i will once that amendment is made
we'll sign them everyone presumably is
happy with that
good okay now running order for tonight
we are going to adjust the running order
ever so slightly we do have two items
where no uh no one is registered to
speak so in line with our rules and
procedures we will bring those forward
and we have an option to delegate so the
first of those is application number 21
0 5
3 6 f u l and that is the grange block
in ships and star i propose that we did
bring that forward and delegate could i
have a second to please councillor
jennings we'll have a show of hands for
those in favor
that is unanimous fabulous thank you
very much and uh the other items bring
forward is item owes application number
21 0 00895 ful um in henley and arden
once again i propose that we bring that
forward and delegate could have a
secondary please counselor crump show of
hands please
it's unanimous marvelous thank you very
much everybody
okay
let's get into our first item then our
first full application which is
application number twenty one zero one
six zero zero ful that is seven benson
road instructor upon having our
presenting officers sarah mcpherson
sarah over to you
hello perfect
this application site is within the
built up area boundary of stratford
identified here by the black dot
the site is identified here by the red
line the purple line indicates the
conservation area we can see that the
application site lies outside but
directly adjacent to the conservation
area
the dashed green line show groups of
trees protected by a tree preservation
order on the adjacent site
this is the existing site plan which
shows the existing dwelling the parking
area and garden and also the
neighbouring properties
and here are the existing elevations
where we can see that the dwelling is a
simple two-story dwelling
this is the proposed site plan showing
the proposed apartment block of six
apartments
two
one bed apartments and four two bed
apartments
the parking area is to the front and
there's a communal garden to the rear
here is the proposed front elevation
this has been amended through the course
of the application in order to add a
greater level of architectural detailing
including lintel sills and bay windows
the red dash line indicates the outline
of the existing property the dashed
purple line include indicates the
outline of a previous version of the
application which was refused earlier
this year
here is the proposed rear elevation
which is more contemporary each dwelling
would have a private balcony and the
rear garden would be communal
and here are the proposed side
elevations
this is the proposed street scene from
benson road
and this is a side-by-side comparison of
the existing and proposed site plans
turning to the photos this is the
property the existing property from
benson road
and a closer image
this is looking from the west with the
application site indicated with the red
arrow
this is looking from the east
this is the neighboring property of
welcome grange which is the only other
property which fronts benson road in
this immediate vicinity
this is an aerial view supplied by the
applicant which shows the application
site and its neighboring properties
and this is an aerial view sort of from
the rear showing the application sites
identified by the red arrow
and the final slide is just a
replication of the existing and proposed
site plans
to sum up the application for the
demolition of an existing dwelling and
erection of six apartments is
recommended for approval and i would
draw members attention to the update
sheet where an error on the report has
been corrected
thank you
so thank you very much we will move to
our
first speaker of the evening who is
councillor kevin taylor of stratford
town council mr taylor if you'd like to
make your way forward
i should say councillor taylor i'm
afraid sorry about them
so good evening um
you have three minutes uh i will give
you a 30 second warning and then let you
know when your time is up otherwise
whenever you're ready if you press the
button in the middle to turn the
microphone on feel free to start
thank you very much good evening
everyone uh as the ward councillor for
the welcome ward for stratford-upon-avon
town council
it's always been a great disappointment
to me that we've never been able to
utilize this site that has stood long
undeveloped for such a long period of
time
and been subject to many actions of
vandalism
and anti-social behavior
when the initial application was
submitted
um town council initially uh
uh allocated a no reps situation however
then i visited the site
and spoke to both the residents and the
developer
and i personally objected to the initial
application because i felt that the the
size of the development in particular in
the intrusion on the neighbours at
welcome grange was was was excessive
and i gave the developer a number of
recommendations that i felt needed to be
addressed prior to submitting the new
application and bringing it back to town
council
planning consultative committee for
advice
certainly when the developer returned
with this information tank i and town
council
believe that they have addressed all the
issues the improvement in design that
have addressed the issues with the
previous application
the introduction of a proportional and
sympathetic landscaping plan that
increases green infrastructure and
improves biodiversity
and the comprehensive daylight and
sunlight overshadowing report
wandering to rigorous industry standards
demonstrated that the proposal had no
adverse impact on the neighbours at
welcome grange
the development meets both core strategy
and neighborhood development plan
policies on the effective use of vacant
land and brownfield sites within a
highly sustainable location to go
against the policy could set a dangerous
precedent to prevent development on
other suitable sites in the future or
discourage them from being brought
forward by developers
therefore putting more pressure on
greenfield sites to meet housing needs
forcing developments out of sustainable
locations
so i would like to fully support this
development
and i and town council have already uh
recommended that we support it
and i think it's time that this site in
some manner was developed
and produce something of a similar
standard of the developments either side
of the current plot thank you very much
i was just about to give you a 30 second
warning so well done perfect timing
members do we have any questions for
cancer taylor
no
very good in that case cancer thank you
very much thank you you're already
wiping the table down so i appreciate
that
and while you're doing that if i could
call forward uh um
mr gary moss on behalf of the residents
good evening mr moss
um i think you know the drill you've
been here a few times before so you
actually have six minutes um you just
patrol as little of it as you like uh
again i'll give you a 30 second warning
and then i'll let you know when your
time is up otherwise when you're ready
feel free to start
thank you very much chairman thank you
members
i represent the residents of welcome
grange and stratfor court the two
adjacent buildings
the residents i represent do not object
to some form of development on this site
it just needs to be the right
development
the previous application was refused on
grounds that the overall mass and bulk
of the development its width
its impact on the street scene and
impact on neighboring immunity were all
unacceptable
this latest application seeks to address
these refusal reasons by making the
following amendments a reduction in the
ridge height and eaves height
marginal reduction in the width of
development
amendments to the external design and
reduced car parking by two spaces
the development plan in line with the
framework puts great emphasis on design
this has recently been reinforced with
the changes to the framework
furthermore the site lies adjacent to
the conservation area whereby even
greater emphasis needs to be adhered to
unfortunately the changes made by the
applicant remain unacceptable for the
following reasons
unacceptable impact on neighbouring
residential immunity the previous scheme
was refused based at the proposed
development was considered to give rise
to overbearing and overshadowing impacts
upon navy residential properties at
welcome grange due to the breaching of
the 45 and 25 degree line tests the
short side-to-side separation distance
the distance to which the proposed
development extends beyond the rear
elevation
of welcome grange
however
this development still breaches both the
45 and 25 degree tests
the changing footprint is negligible as
to its position to the boundary to
welcome grange
and there has been no reduction in terms
of the depth of built form
residents accept that the current
dwelling on site breaches some of these
tests but this is lower in height
further from the boundary
and significantly shorter in plan depth
whilst the applicant's daylight and
sunlight assessment sought to address
the issues of loss of light
it fails to address the impact of over
pairing and loss of outlook
something the case officer considers is
addressed merely by the reduction in
height with no reference to the extent
of built form along the boundary
a key reason for the previous refusal
in respect to this point the development
remains unchanged and creates a solid
war projection around 90 meters in
length along the boundary of welcome
grange
furthermore the development starts from
three metres forward of the rear ward of
welcome grange so effectively results in
a length of water from 22 meters long at
a height of 6.6 meters to eaves
this wall is only broken up by a few
windows
secondly unacceptable impact on the
character appearance of the area and the
conservation area once again the
previous scheme was refused by the
council due to the government's
excessive bulk massing form layout the
large four court parking area and the
lack of landscaping
this being harmful to the character
appearance of the street scene
it also
raised issues that the harm to the
setting of the significance of the
heritage asset was not overcome by
public benefits
again some changes have been made and
there are some improvements however the
building is still
large in terms of its massing
its position on a relatively narrow and
small plot
and still detracts from the appearance
of the street z remains too large within
this plot and is not sensitive to its
setting or the local character the
retained large front parking area
despite attempts still is overly
dominant meaning car parking will still
be the predominant form
i know the officer's report states that
a smaller development might be
preferable the residents would argue
this is a necessity
and that the development does not fit
well on this constrained site
thirdly unacceptable impact on future
occupies amenity
the development because of its size and
position means the level of immunity
provided to future residents is limited
especially when you consider it to those
of welcome grange and stratfor core
adjacent
the layout proximity to boundary and the
general site constraints means that
light penetration to future occupiers
will be limited
increasing use of artificial lighting
this is a poor design and runs contrary
to the council's objectives addressing
climate change and energy efficiency in
buildings
fourth unacceptable impact on existing
trees
the application site has a number of
mature trees along its boundaries which
are visual importance and many statute
protected or in third party land
ownership
landscaping is key to the character of
the area and helps define its leafy
suburb character
given the size scan and position of the
building to these trees and despite the
assurances given in the application it
is likely harm will be caused
and pressure created to excessively
manage these trees
to the detriment of their health and
longevity
in conclusion
the amendments made to the scheme do not
overcome the previous reasons for
refusal
the development by virtue of its design
layout excessive bulk and massing
remains unacceptable in terms of its
impact on the character of the street
scene
setting of the conservation area the
development also negatively impacts upon
the immunity of residents at welcome
grange in particular due to the length
of projection and proximity to the
boundary causing unacceptable
overshadowing overbearing and a poor
outlook and to those in stratford court
in addition the development would fail
to provide future residents with
sufficient and good quality immunity
it puts greater pressure on existing
trees and landscaping a key feature of
the area 30 seconds
so in conclusion the application cannot
be supported it is country development
plan and does not comprise a sustainable
form of development in accordance with
the framework thank you very much
members
thank you very much mr master members do
we have any questions for casa crump
thank you mr moss um you mentioned lots
of that look i didn't quite hear what
you said after that could you just
explain uh go into that a bit further
please
in in terms of the residence outlook
yeah so i think it's probably easiest by
referring to the planet hopefully
members will see that
the position of the new building
which is
one set further back into the site to
allow for the park and vision to the
front
but more importantly its proximity and
projection in terms of its depth along
the boundary
means that the rear area of welcome
grange
which is the area to
the left-hand side closest to the car
parking where you've got habitable
windows their outlook is effectively now
resorted in a tunneling effect so
basically the outlook as well as the
overbearing of that 6.6 metre wall would
have an adverse impact on that immunity
i fully understand there thank you
council adam
thank you um can you just um clarify how
many residents live in
the properties that you that you're
representing here tonight
uh apologies i can't give you the actual
exact numbers i think i think it's seven
or eight flats in welcome grange
um i think there's more in stratford
court it's a bigger building but the
number i couldn't tell you
see a lot of nodding from behind you so
i'm assuming you've got that number
right um any other questions members
no in that case mr moss thank you very
much if you i was gonna say if you could
wipe it down that'd be great you're
already there good man thank you
while you do that i will put forward our
next speaker who is mr dominic skinner
our agent mrs skinner if you'd like to
make your way forward please
this is gonna good evening i think again
you probably know the drill so you'll
have three minutes i'll give you a 30
second warning uh and obviously when
your time is up if you remain seated for
questions otherwise whenever you're
ready it's over to you
thank you chair a previous application
for this site was rejected in february
of this year
this early application was diffused on a
number of points
impact on the street scene due to
excessive mass and bulk
lack of landscaping to the front and
overshadowing to neighborhood
residential properties at welcome grange
the application here for consideration
has addressed the issues with the
previous previous submission and has
therefore gained the support of the
planning officer and the town council
the proposed site is in a highly
sustainable location and the proposed
development makes the most effective use
of this site
it also demonstrates alignment with
local policies that encourage and
support the effective use of vacant
plots for development
the proposal provides one and two bed
accommodation within a town centre
location
meeting a housing need identifying both
the core strategy and neighbourhood
development plan this opportunity to
provide such accommodation should be
supported
in order to reduce the impact on
neighbouring dwellings the proposed
design has been greatly scaled back the
eaves and ridgeline have been lowered
and the volume of the dwelling has been
reduced by 24
this creates a dwelling more subservient
sympathetic and proportional to its
neighbors as demonstrated by the
submitted street scene
all mature hedging and trees on site
will be retained a low level wall with a
mixture of low and high level planting
to the front will serve to screen the
parking area
high level mature planting will provide
a visual screen to further obscure
proposed dwelling from neighbouring view
a robust and thorough daylight sunlight
and overshadowing assessment has been
completed to a company's application
the assessment was completed by
specialist consultants to strict
industry recognized requirements
this demonstrates the pose development
causes no unacceptable harm on
neighbouring dwellings the lowering of
the roofline and eaves means that only
sections of the roof gate would be
visible above the boundary and headrings
this application has taken a positive
and proactive approach to address the
issues with the previous previous
submission
most notably to improve the appearance
of the dwelling helping to enhance the
existing street scene and sit
sympathetically within its environment
dramatically reduce the overall mass
height and bulk of the proposal
alterations which have been proven to
cause no unacceptable harm to
neighboring dwellings
retention of trees and hedging and the
introduction of a sympathetic and
proportion landscaping scheme helping to
screen the proposal from neighboring
dwellings
the scheme provides a balanced
development one that demonstrates a
positive reaction to local planning
policies in the appropriate use of land
and the meeting of identified housing
need in a highly sustainable location 30
seconds the application has demonstrated
a balance in favor of approval as
supported by this council's own policies
planning officer and town council
i therefore respectfully ask this
council to vote for its approval thank
you chair
mr thank you very much just within your
time well done members do we have any
questions for mr skinner please
don't all jump at once no looks like
it's covered everything so if again if
you wouldn't mind wiping down the desk
for me that'd be great and thank you
very much for your contribution
our final speaker on this item is
councillor jefferson council jefferson
would you like to make your way forward
council jefferson good evening welcome
again i think you probably know the
drill by now you have five minutes i'll
give you a 30 second warning and let you
know when your time's up otherwise it's
over to you
thank you mr chair
first i must make it very clear that
i've got no objection to the principle
of development of this site
i would also just like to say that i've
now visited the site three times
uh
i'd also point out that sdc currently
has a housing balance supply of 7.02
years
there's therefore no immediate pressure
to accept planning applications
merely to increase the number of housing
units
the undeniable fact is that the site is
virtually derelict and an eyesore but
this is not i think a valid planning
reason for approving this application
the previous planning application was
rejected by the planning officer for the
following reasons which i'm summarizing
as follows
excessive bulk and massing and too large
within the plot
incongruous form of development not
considered sensitive to its setting
introducing an incongruous form of
development
is considered to give rise to
overbearing and overshadowing impacts on
neighboring residential properties at
welcome grange
due to breaching the 45-25 degree line
test the short side to side separation
distance provided and the distance to
which the proposed development extends
beyond the rear elevation of the
westernmost portion of welcomed range
and actually if you look at the diagrams
on the screen you can see just how far
it does extend beyond
that
rear beyond that westernmost portion
and frankly despite the changes in the
current application the fundamentals i
think have not changed and i think all
the reasons given for the rejection of
the previous application are still valid
it remains an overdevelopment and in
congress development of the plot
there's still i think an adverse impact
on the immunity of welcome grange
residents
there are now some very specific issues
i want to look at
i know the planning offices report
states that the 45-25 degree line test
is still breached
and although there's some breaches of
the 45-25 degrees occurring within
within the existing development with the
increasing massing of the development
the effects would be increased and
neighbouring immunity immediately
correspondingly effective
i'd also agree with the comment of the
planning office of rejection of the
previous application that
the proposed site layout with a large
full court
only serves to add to the feeling of a
commercial unit and detracts further
from the street sea
and although there's some landscaping in
the current
planning application
they do go somewhere to softening the
impact but they don't change the
fundamentals
in considering the rear communal garden
the planning office's report clearly
states
while this amount of outdoor space is
less than is desired by the development
requirements spd it is considered
sufficient for flats of this type in a
town center location
i would question whether this is really
a town center location given where it is
located right on the edge of the
built-up area boundary
uh
i just had a personal view on this after
the curving pandemic and given the high
probability of further pandemics
is this not and this isn't should not be
an area for compromise this could have a
serious impact on future occupiers
immunity
turning to the our body cultural impact
assessment is pretty clear it states
very clearly there is a conflict with
the trees that cannot be
avoided
and the successful retention of those
trees that will remain on site will be
dependent on the quality and maintenance
of any protection system that's put in
place
it appears to me from this statement
that trees will be at risk and given the
proximity of the development of plot
boundaries it could easily adversely
affect trees and vegetation on
neighbouring properties
so i really do think that despite this
latest round of improvements there are
still more than enough relevant planning
reasons to reject this application 30
seconds it appears to subtract far far
more value from the neighborhood and
adds little in the way of benefits
i'd respectfully urge you to reject this
application
thank you
thank you very much jefferson we're all
been very good on our timing tonight um
members do we have any questions council
crump please
thank you mr chairman hi tony um
my concern is that the council has an
spd and i've touched on previous
applications as well in my own ward
um
and it says it's a
convenient walking distance of the
immunities of stratford-ten center
but in the spd it requires we have
should have at least 11.2 spaces here
and antenna being provided
um
this is my concern we have an spd yes we
have to have some level of pragmatism
but if we have an spd and then we start
having pragmatism
and a bit of leeway um
where does that leave the spd especially
in particular on this case as well
i'm i'm going to pause you there that's
not directly relevant to this
application that's relevant to an spd
okay
you might want to reframe it i'll
rephrase the question in the light of
the council have an spd that's gone
through a lot of
processes what is your opinion that
the spd says that we should have 10.2
spaces for this allocate application and
they're only providing 10.
you are talking about car parking spaces
i think the reality for me is that if
you look at stratford on haven as a
district
it's heavily car dependent
the fact actually is that if people live
in flats even in stratford
they probably work elsewhere
they've then got
an awful lot of relatives friends etc to
say that probably do not live in the
district
i think the reality is that if one
doesn't allocate enough car parking
spaces we end up with cars parked on the
road
which is not good
and particularly in that part of the
town there are double yellow lines
almost everywhere
and the
car parking the on street car parking
spaces are massively over subscribed
that's right um do we have any other
questions members
no in that case council jefferson thank
you very much contribution if you could
please give the desk a quick wipe that
would be very appreciated
okay members we will now move into our
questions for our officer if we have any
questions or points of clarification
council jennings first please
thanks jim
um it's been brought up about the 45 and
25 degree angle um
ruling on this and when i noticed when
we went there the
this afternoon
and there are a number of trees which
looked as if on the plans as if they
were there but they were no longer there
um could you give me a bit of
clarification on that please
yeah it's my understanding that some
trees um perhaps on both sides of the
boundary um
have been removed during the course of
the application in the last few months
however my recommendation isn't based on
those trees being there or not as your
no trees can be removed um without
planning permission not being in a
conservation area or um protected
assuming you mean the boundary between
the application site and and welcome
grange on the right yes um yeah they're
not protected trees so they could be
removed at will of either party so my
assessment wasn't based on those being
there or not and that said we would
ensure via condition a robust planting
scheme at the boundary to sort of soften
the impact and that's
in the report as a recommended condition
so have a further question if possible
um
the
some of you mentioned some of the trees
have got tpos on them um what is the
radius where
where they can build or how far away
they got to be from the tpos
because again a lot of the trees seem to
be very close to where
this
new house and you say new block of flats
are going to be built
yeah so
yeah it's working now um there's a group
of protected trees sort of the bottom
right hand corner here and they were
evaluated in the submitted arbor
cultural statement
and it concluded that they're subject to
working practices being in accordance
with that method statement um there
wouldn't be any adverse impact on the
trees um and that is going to be a
condition that's a recommended condition
that works are undertaken in accordance
with the method statement so there
shouldn't be any impact
uh before i call in cancer dixon where
um cancer joining has mentioned the 45
25 degree rule um i've highlighted that
from a number of our speakers and i can
see you've referred to it in your report
but i'm trying to understand why exactly
um you are okay with a breach of that
45-25 degree rule
yeah um so i did refuse the application
earlier in the year um a very similar
application i should say it has been
reduced um for this application um and
one of the grounds was the 45 25 degree
line being breached as you can see on
this plan it is already breached um in
respect of the existing dwelling um but
the proposal would be larger and
therefore sort of give a greater impact
in that regard however with this
application they submitted a sunlight
and daylight assessment which was a very
thorough assessment of the light which
each window of each neighboring property
would receive and all habitable room
windows would receive a negligible
impact according to the results of that
assessment which led me to conclude that
although the 45-25 degree line test has
been breached there would actually be no
adverse impact on those neighbors
have any of our own officers other than
your obviously your good self assessed
the um
that sunlight
pack that came through to you or is it
simply a question of your your
discretion your decision on that um it's
gone through myself and my line manager
david
um okay council dixon
thank you chairman
um have any photographs at all taken
from within the current site which might
depict welcome grange from inside this
site because obviously
my concern and certainly i think
obviously the concern of the residents
is that
potential
high wall along what appears very close
to the boundary so also um it may be in
the report i'm not i immediately found
it what is the distance from the built
wall to the boundary fence or boundary
vegetation etc and have actually any
photographs taken within the grounds
because that looks like it could be a
bit overbearing on
residents at the rear end of
welcome and i'm assuming that when you
have that other plan up there's a white
line which i assume is a patio
but it's not that you know we
can't tell from the photograph
yeah so it's actually very difficult to
get photos from within the application
site itself you can't quite tell on this
aerial image um but the entire rear
garden is overtaken by brambles it's a
very sort of derelict site so you can't
actually get into the rear garden
particularly so
yes i couldn't really take any photos
from within the site but this photo here
does serve to demonstrate um some of
what you were asking um and the let me
see if i if you can see my arrow
here oh can i zoom in yeah i think so
um so that is a patio and i think
this was what you were referring to
and i can give you some information
about the distances on the boundary as
well i'll flip back to the site plan to
show that
so
if you can see my cursor here
the distance between the boundary and
the existing property here is one and a
half meters and this this first
section here which is in a darker gray
that's a single story element and that's
1.5 meters and then if we go over to the
other side of the uh for the proposal
and as you can see the dwelling is set a
bit further back in the site and as we
go back to the site the boundary line
starts to wiggle slightly i'll see if i
can zoom in so it is a bit wiggled um
but the distance between the boundary
and
the edge of the property is between one
and a half to 0.8 meters um at the the
thickest and thinnest points
could you put your microphone on when
you're asking questions please and
there's vegetation proposed along there
yes thank you
and that would be secured by a
landscaping scheme oh gosh
there we go
i'm going to come back on this lighting
thing um because it's new to me um i'm
not questioning your
understanding of it i just want to i've
never seen one before do you get a lot
of those so you have a reasonable but
either if you have a reasonable
experience of having to decipher the
information within them
we've had several um in the district
submitted quite often in respect of the
impact of
large listed trees sorry tpo trees on um
rear windows of proposed dwellings so we
have some experience of looking at them
they are
undertaken to a standard the building
research
establishments standards provides guide
um of how these should be undertaken and
what should be within them
that's what i wanted to hear lovely yeah
i do i didn't want to hear we're just
taking it on trust but if it's the right
standards then i'm actually fine with
that uh members do we have any other
questions uh for our officers at this
point no in which case let's open up the
debate who would like to kick us off
i'm gonna pick on people if they don't
council jennings is there good man
i've got to go
well
after going around the site this
afternoon
it's sort of i think when you do
do some of the side visits it does open
your eyes
to
the actual size of the plot and looking
at the house the property next door the
flats next door thing is the welcome
grange on the right
and obviously that
the
it's a huge they've got a huge plot this
is quite a narrow plot
and i can understand why previously it
was
toned down because of the mass and bulk
and
i certainly agree something has to be
done on this site
however
i'm leaning toward i'm sort of the
opinion that
what's proposed here is still
too big for the too big for the side
um
just seems absolutely excessive but
that's that's what that's what the way
i'm leaning at the moment
i'm going to take it that that is not
yet a formal proposal uh it's just uh
we're just letting us know
okay in that case other members do we
have anyone else that would like to
contribute at this point
cancer adam first
um yeah i suppose slightly to counter i
mean
i i am slightly concerned about the
issues that have been raised by the
objectors
um but i i can't really see
based on what the officers have said
those being material enough to refuse um
against
a recommendation um
there is a a fine line strike but
the way i see it i think actually the
officers probably got it right here i'm
happy to propose we go along with her
recommendation
thank you very much councillor crump
please
i think this is a fine fine difficult
balance on this one
i think has got merits um
[Music]
definitely um
and it certainly improved the plot um i
noticed comment about a seven year house
and land supply
so we can be choosy what we put in there
um
so
my concern relates to the spd
so i think this is a matter of balance
it's difficult one this is a very i'm
finding this one extremely difficult um
because i can see pros and cons on this
one um so i will make my judgment
shortly but it's definitely um
better application than the one before
um
but is it quite right i'm not 100
certain on that one
thank you very much cancer crime
counselor kendall
thank you chairman um
yes like a lot of people who've spoken
so far i'm
i'm really i'm struggling with this one
um because
while i recognize that the
applicant has made great steps towards
reducing this
i can't help but feel that i think i
agree with my counselor jennings this is
still
too big for the plot
um
i think
given that's the case i'll be going down
the route of not supporting this based
on um
bulk massing on an over development of
the site it just feels too big
um so that's the route i'm taking if
perhaps make that as a proposal that we
uh that we refuse
if that helps
uh it does yeah okay um
i haven't seen anyone else indicate so
for what it's worth are you indicating
cancellation stereotyping in that case
i'll let you go first
okay thank you
um i've been visited the site today
and had a good look determined
the um
properties either side are on
a larger plot
but they are a vastly larger buildings
um
i just think
okay the scale of it compared with the
larger ones is probably about the same
on the same scale so
i think
i'll side with the officer's
recommendation
and just just for clarity is that a
second of cancer adam's proposal
yeah okay thank you um
coming back to uh what cancer kendall
said he has obviously proposed uh
refusal for the reasons that he gave
um i'm gonna second that uh if i may um
[Music]
you mentioned size scale bulking um i
think positioning as well looking at the
uh the picture on the right hand side
um
[Music]
the the entire thing is set back so the
starting point is set back behind the
property of at the welcome grange which
in itself i think
i find that difficult to view in the
city in the street scene uh but also has
a
in my mind a significant effect on the
neighbouring property on the welcome
grange so i would add positioning to
that if i would if you don't mind um
that sort of wraps up into neighboring
immunity overbearing overshadowing
um and again as i say
positioning but also we've heard about
immunity value of future residents and
um that it doesn't quite meet our
minimum standards um i do believe we
should be meeting those minimum
standards there's no point having a
minimum standards if we're gonna ignore
it uh similarly with parking um doesn't
mean i'm minimum standards in terms of
parking so i would add those two on as
as reasons for refusal as well so i
believe that ends up being three reasons
of refusal unless of course you want to
split the first one into two different
things
um while you're writing that down i'll
have a look across to our planning
manager and see if he has anything that
he'd like to add or say at this point
you don't have to if you don't want to
thank you for the opportunity chair
as i read the room you have a proposal
and a second for the
officer's recommendation and a second
proposal and a second of
a proposed overturn refusal um
i'll address the second uh
proposal first if you like the proposal
to overturn um i'm understanding from
from your own comments that matters
relating to size scale bulk setback the
position of the
proposed building within the site and
the impact that that would have on
neighbouring immunity
the fact that that therefore wouldn't
meet the guidance in respect of
the spd
for the 45 and 25 degree rule
um i would suggest perhaps that that's
all a single reason as they all
are
views which relate to policy cs9 of the
course strategy
in respect of comments around the spd
and the parking standards
i think i would draw members attention
to
the lines within the guidance there
which say these standards will be used
as a guide having regard to the size of
the dwelling that is to be created the
likely parking demand arising the impact
upon highway safety the accessibility of
the development and the level of
provision that already exists on site
i think
those words within our spd suggest that
the standards in the spd relating to
number of parking spaces
are not
outright categorical science standards
and there is a matter of planning
judgment to be used and that's what you
read in the case officers report
so i would
suggest to members that that is a less
strong reason for refusal than the
matters relating to design which seem
more coherent to my mind and more
related to our policy setting to our
lead members to
consider that in in their own fashion
okay thank you so the future immunity
value in terms of the garden land and
stuff you're going to include that in
the first reason just unclear um in
terms of the parking um my planning
judgment
is that given the location it is on a
bend it is double yellow lined all the
way up i had a challenge parking there
for the site visit today um
we are talking about flats that
inevitably will have at least one if not
two occupiers i think there is a need in
that location for um sufficient car
parking and that it doesn't meet that
standard so that's my opinion um council
kendall it was your proposal are you
satisfied that we include that and yeah
that's fine so we've got those reasons
set down now um
we do have to take our first proposal
which is to grant first and we'll come
to that in just a second but before we
do does anyone else have anything they
want to contribute to the debate at this
point
no in that case um the proposal in front
of you now uh proposed by council adam
uh seconded by council hencher serafin
is to grant permission um for
application 2101 600 ful could have a
show of hands for those in favor of
granting police
that's two and those against
five children and those abstaining
one one so that in that case that failed
so our second proposal is to refuse the
reasons given proposed by council
kendall seconded by myself current show
of hands for those in favor of refusal
and for those against
two and abstentions
one therefore committee resolves to
refuse application reference twenty one
zero one six zero zero full seven benson
a road in stratfor upon even
thank you very much um okay let's move
to our next item
which is application reference twenty
one zero one zero six five ful that is
also rugby football club uh in king's
coffin coffin code sorry i always get
that mixed up i do apologize in king's
cotton um our presenting officer is
stuart flair teacher whenever you're
ready it's over to you
janice
thank you chairman uh good evening
uh this application is seeking
retrospective planning permission for
the erection of a canopy at an existing
hand car wash facility
the application site is within an area
of open countryside and is washed over
by the green belt
indicated by this black dot on the plan
here we see a plan denoting the location
of the site the red line indicates the
actual application site itself
we're also within a designated special
landscaping area
here we see a site layout plan uh
showing the canopy uh here
we then see the rugby clubhouse here and
access is taken from the a road here
we then have some elevational detail of
the canopy itself
as has just been mentioned this is a
retrospective application therefore the
canopy is already in situ as you can see
here we have it as we're stood on the
point of vehicle access of the a-road
and here's just a
further photo showing it a wider setting
with some neighboring properties on the
other side of the road
finally here we see the canopy from
further away
here one stood on the a-road
this proposal looks to support a local
business in its daily operations
offices are a view that there are clear
and demonstrable very special
circumstances that taken collectively as
a whole outweigh identified harm to the
greenbelt uh there are no updates to
report chairman the recommendation is to
grant the reasons to downpage 65 of your
agendas thank you
thank you very much we'll move to our
first speaker who is councillor beau
from ulster town council do we have
councillor beau here with us
it looks like that's a no
somebody just said
yeah
bear with
um we're just going to take a couple of
seconds while we we try and
change that chat down
i know
but it's the right
okay so we've had confirmation then that
uh the ulster town council aren't here
now under normal procedures we would of
course delegate this however uh we have
had miranda rogers
uh who is shaking her head saying she
doesn't want to speak anymore um you
have been so patient i was going to give
you the opportunity if you want to speak
you can um if you don't want to speak
that's also fine and we can delegate
okay in that case members it looks like
a given we have no one from the town
council here who caused this to come to
committee i propose we delegate to
officers secondly by council kendall a
show of hands police
unanimous marvelous in that case
we have delegated that item perfect
let's move on to our final item of the
evening which is application
2101035 full stepping stones in
lighthorn
um stuart if you want to start whenever
you're ready
that's mr pierce
right stuart just bow with me a second
because it looks like we don't have
council longhorn here either
let me just get legal advice uh on how
we're gonna do this just bear with me
okay stu if you want to go ahead with
your presentation please
thank you chairman
um this proposal seeking full plan
admission for the installation of a loft
conversion raising of the ridge height
of the roof and the introduction of
timber cladding and other associated
developments
the application site has been the
village of lightshorn shown on the black
darkness plan
here we see a plan once again denoting
the location of the site
the red line boundary is shown here we
are also within sight we are inside the
conservation area
here we see elevational detail um
provided by the applicant of what is
proposed uh on the left is the existing
layout
on the right proposed
and similarly
the other elevations
as per on this screen
this proposal looks to increase the
number of bedrooms from four to six
um here we are stood on church lane
looking northeast at the existing
dwelling
uh and once again we are still on the
same road this time looking north west
um officers review that this is a
proposed development that harmonizes
with the local vernacular
um please refer members to the update
sheets for a tweak to your report um
chairman the recommendations to grant
for a reason set out on pages 74 and 75
of your agendas thank you mr thanks very
much indeed our first speaker on this
item is councillor mike longhorn do we
have a council longhorn here
marvelous good evening sir welcome thank
you for your patience while we've made
it through the rest of the agenda
good evening so you have three minutes
um i will give you a 30 second warning
for your time is up and then of course i
will let you know when your time is up
otherwise whenever you're ready feel
free to start
uh you will need to press the button in
the middle it'll turn red
there we go okay
okay
um thank you mr chairman the um
i talk on behalf of the parish council
who see this proposal as an
overdevelopment in a sensitive
conservation area
giving rise to potential damage to a
heritage assets with some concomitant
parking and highways issues
i've
put forward a few photographs i don't
have control over the photographs the
first one i wanted to bring to your
attention was just a
yes there it is um
the
planning application is in a site in
proximity to the centre of the
conservation area this just gives you a
flavor for those who aren't familiar
with the village of the nature and
character of the center of the
conservation area
if we move on
to the next image which
shows the street scene and the proposed
site
the proposal involves in increasing the
massing
of the building by increasing the ruth
height and
whilst the officer points out in the
report that there is a
neighbouring property that has a similar
roof height what i would point out to
the committee is the vast majority of
properties along church lane
are lower on a single story development
and if i can just ask you to flip to a
next photograph
here's an illustration of the majority
of properties along church lanes that
are of um
low massing and low roof height
so
first people point out that we believe
the officers got it wrong
that the majority of properties are of
lower roof height than the proposed
development
our view is that the property will be an
over development and
i noticed that the officer in the report
asserts that there's a certain um
sight and garden size we do believe that
in fact this is a manifest error
the
our assessment of the size is it's 64
meter squared which is
similar to the 62 meter squared
reference in the report has been
appropriate for fulbright property
however if this development procedures
it turns the development into a six
bedroom property
which to our mind demonstrates very very
clearly that this is over development of
a compromised narrow site
can i just move on to the next
photograph please 30 seconds
okay
parking and highways are an issue
yes here's the picture of the drive and
the garage
by creating a six bedroom property there
will be more vehicles there's
little storage in the site and
car parking could be expected to spill
onto the pavement
and it is a very narrow lane
where there is restrictions both for
pedestrians and vehicular access
um can i just flick back to an earlier
photograph please
i am going to have to ask you to wrap up
okay
so thank you very much so in summary uh
the reason we object is that it's over
development of
of a site it's in a conservation area
and we do actually think that there are
some errors that the officer has made
concerning sizing and which reinforces
the over development criteria
that's a long haul thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our parish council
donald jump at once no looks like we've
covered everything longhorns thank you
very much for your patience and
contribution this evening
if you could please give the desk a
quick wipe down that'd be appreciated
and while you're doing that i will call
forward our next speaker here with mr
john pearce speaking on behalf of the
applicants mr pearce please make your
way forward
so mr pierce you have three minutes as
well i will once again give you a 30
second warning let you know when your
time's up otherwise whenever you're
ready do feel free to start
good evening i'm representing the
applicant who's unable to attend this
evening so i'm reading his statement
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to support the application
the main part of the application is a
loft extension this would slightly
increase the roof height so i can create
two additional bedrooms as i work from
home it would also separate the
workspace from the home space
the existing roof is 50 years old it has
leaks and requires further repairs
as it is on unusually low i feel
replacing it with a more orthodox roof
pitch would be a big improvement
it to the appearance of the dwelling
the proposed roof pitch would be more in
keeping with the majority of roofs in
the village and it would be the same as
the nearest neighbor
the application also proposes timber
cladding to the exterior walls
this would not be an unreasonable change
as there is a wide mix of materials in
the area
the footprint to the dwelling has not
changed since the house was built and it
would not change now the existing
spacious garden
would remain therefore i don't consider
there will be any over development of
the site
i understand the concerns of the parish
council but feel that the proposals are
reasonable and wouldn't affect
neighbours
proposed roof lights would not
afford any more overlooking
opportunities than the windows that are
already in place
high hedges also at the rear remove
any opportunity for overlooking from the
rear as well
officers have already explained
how the distances to neighbours fully
meet the council's requirements
with regard to parking the extension
would be for family members
there would be no additional demand for
parking the site has a double garage and
driveway and provides for four
four parking spaces in all which exceeds
the counters cancer's
requirements
removal of a short section of
overgrown out of control hedge at the
front would not impact overall
on the landscape character in the sign
the hedge is set back from the road
the prominent landscaping to church lane
and the 35 meter long hedge to the rear
boundary would remain and provide plenty
of
nesting for
birds this application represents a very
modest change
which respects
the character and appearance
of the conservation area
i would respectfully ask that the
planning committee endorse the officer's
recommendation and grant permission
thank you i struggle because i've got no
reading glasses
you struggled very well
if i could have this
um i i lived in this house for 40 odd
years and i put my knee out getting in
the loft to get the christmas
decorations down and always cursed it
and it still hurts
my contribution to christmas girl are
you in a position to answer questions on
behalf of the applicant sorry are you in
a position to answer questions on behalf
of the applicant i think you said you
were reading on behalf of someone else
because they couldn't be i'm speaking on
behalf of the applicant but i live next
door okay and i'm in favor of it anyway
okay so i'm going to open up questions
for members to you so members are there
any questions i should have asked that
first ready because it's gonna be a no
isn't it looking at everyone's faces
in that case uh mr pierce thank you very
much again for your patience and your
contribution this evening thank you um
we will move on with the meeting so
members will open up for um points
clarification officers anyone got any
questions or points of clarification
looks like a no let's move to debate who
would like to kick us off oh hang on
council jennings you have a point of
clarification yes sorry it was raised
about the sizing issues um
[Music]
is there any ambiguity here
sorry can't deciding on what sorry there
was a
the
the speaker the first speaker
um
yeah council longhorn said that there
was a discrepancy in the sizing issue
i believe that's really that related to
the guard regarding uh the sizing that
you're referring to yeah um i can only
think that uh there may be a typo
potentially in this report i would be
very surprised if there was
293 square meters of garden space um
what i can't give you is a precise
measurement of what that garden is um
i would remain overview whilst it is not
293 square meters that this rear garden
space would still be in excess of our
minimum space standards for what would
now be a six bed dwelling
um
by virtue of
the four bed and six bed standard is
actually one on the same
which is 62 square meters so
um i would be satisfied that this still
meets that minimum standard and exceeds
it indeed
okay excellent thank you very much
okay thank you there being no one else
looking for a point of clarification
we will move on to debate who's going to
kick us off on the debate i'm going to
pick on councillor jennings because he
shoved in at the last minute a question
to officers so cancer jennings you want
to kick us off
my thoughts on on this one
and i was just
looking at the highways that the
highways seem seeing fine with it
um
my my inclination at the moment is to go
along with the officer's
recommendation
um i don't struggling to see a reason to
go against it
so
i've kicked off someone else is that a
proposal to grant in line with offers a
recommendation it is marvellous good man
counselor kendall please i'll jump in
and second that straight away but i
would say as even as a member of parish
council myself i do understand that
parish councils especially in
conservation areas are very
conservative small c in order to make
you know they don't like change i can't
certainly understand the parish
council's view on this in terms of it
expanding as a building but i really
can't find any planning grounds to go
against the officer's recommendation so
that's what i'm seconding good stuff
cancer fleming did you indicate cancer
[Music]
because it doesn't sort of change the
footprint
it doesn't change the overlooking
perspective
doesn't change people's view of
what they can see at the windows and
whatever else i can see no reasons at
all why would refuse it thank you
thank you very much does anyone else
have anything they would like to add to
the debate at this point
no in that case we have a proposal to
grant that has been seconded um could we
please have a show of hands flows in
favor
that is unanimous so committee therefore
resolves your grant application 21 0 1 0
3 5 ful now members um we have a slight
uh change of
plan i'm afraid and this is uh open to
you
we have as you know
moved to delegate application uh 21 0 1
0 6 5 full ulster rugby football club um
we now have our speakers here
all of them
so we can if we choose
pull back that delegation
and then go ahead and listen to our full
speakers or
we can continue to move forward and
there being no urgent uh business i can
close the meeting it is
up to the committee so
council dixon would like to speak
thank you chairman i propose that we
change our opinion on the previous one
and we bring the item back to this
committee
seconded by council adam um
we have a quick show of hands for those
in favor of doing that please
that's two flows against doing that
crying out loud
abstentions for
i have the casting vote
you love to give me a headache don't you
you guys
go along with
i
i'm sure it was outside of the control
of the parish council and our ward
member for not being here there are
significant amounts of roadworks that
caused me to be late a number of times
we did
go and have a look for you just so
you're aware we took five minutes to
find you both
given you're here
i do think it would be unfair not to
hear what you've got to say
so
we will hear from you we have already
had the present day
we will hear the presentation again and
then we'll go through our speakers
we did give the opportunity for
the
the applicants to speak earlier on so it
gives them an opportunity they are still
here if they weren't here i wouldn't be
allowing this just so you're just so
we're clear because they're here we are
going to allow it so
stuart if you wouldn't mind
going through again if you wouldn't mind
doing it reasonably quickly and then we
can start to listen
just i can i can see some shakes of
heads and and people saying effect we
have checked this with monitoring
officer um to check full procedure um
and we are adhering to it so
legal services manager i do apologize
monitoring officer so
we
we are going to proceed and hear it um
so stu over to you
thank you chairman um this proposal
seeking retrospective planning
permission for the erection of a canopy
um here is a black dot showing the
location of the site we are washed over
by the green belt in addition to being
an open countryside uh here is the red
line location plan
uh here is the proposed canon what
canopy as it is sits currently in situ
uh elevational detail of the canopy
um and then photograph photographic
evidence showing the canopy uh in situ
for the imagery
and then finally we see the canopy from
a further distance away along the a road
uh as a reminder this proposal seeks to
support a local business in its daily
day-to-day operations uh officers are
our review that they are clear and
different for very special circumstances
that taken collectively outweigh the
harm caused the green belt uh there are
no updates chairman
the recommendation is to grant on us on
page 65 of your agenda thank you
stu thank you very much if we could have
our first speaker counselor mike beau if
you'd like to come forward please uh any
of the desks it doesn't matter which
um you have three minutes so and i'll
give you 30 second warning for your time
is that as soon as you're settled and
ready to go it's over to you there'll be
a button in the middle to turn your
microphone on otherwise over to you
okay thank you very much for um
making this uh
opportunity for us um
i would like to say that also town
council object on the ground that the
canopy is inappropriate in this setting
and causing harm to the green belt the
case office calls on several documents
when assessing the key principles of
development chief amongst those are the
core strategy and the mppf
and because strategy cs1 2223 and as10
parts m and n
are the main categories
we disagree with the case officer's
assessment of these policies for the
following reasons
cs1 is not met on the grounds that the
canopy does not contribute to the
character and quality of the district
cs22 no additional jobs have been
created demonstrating that the canopy
has not fostered growth and
competitiveness
and cs23 no new or enhanced business
offerings are evident therefore this
element is not met
as 10 the canopy's impact is one of harm
in respect to part m the area where the
car wash is situated is um there are no
constructed buildings so small scale
expansion of buildings does not really
apply uh to this
and in part n
there is no suggestion that the business
will be forced to relocate if the
application is refused therefore this
again is not an appropriate
consideration
regards the green belt the case officer
relies on cs10 and the national plan
for his assessment and confirms that the
canopy is inappropriate
he notes for very special circumstances
and relies on economic benefits
local need for this facility and
community benefits in his conclusions
we argue that these exist already and
are not dependent on the canopy
employee numbers are static at five
three fully and two part time and have
not increased since the installing the
canopy suggesting that no applicable
commercial benefit has accrued as a
result of the canopy
the benefit to local needs is the car
wash not the canopy
and it appears that us ulster rugby club
benefits come from rental income from
the car wash which is unchanged by the
installation of the canopy
the car wash is operated profitably for
seven years without a canopy
he also refers to cs5 9 12 in the course
strategy and
ndp policy hbe 8 and it doesn't explain
what those policies actually mean so
i've elaborated and we'll elaborate on
those cs5 refers to landscape
which identifies character and quality
cs9a design and distinctiveness relates
to improving the quality of the public
realm
cs 9b
section 2 is sensitive states that the
proposals will be sensitive to the
setting
and cs 12
special landscape areas the development
management consideration section 2 notes
on an individual basis some proposals
may seem innocuous but cumulatively they
could form part of a general decline in
the quality of landscape
atc's positions that this canopy meets
none of those policy requirements
and if it's approved we fear the
floodgates with open
to other applications causing further
decline in the quality of the landscape
the world councillor sits behind me will
reference the applicant's history in
relation to their approach to seeking
planning permission for proposals and
also highlight matters
relationships sorry to interrupt you i'm
going to have to stop that i was so
engaged with what you're saying i missed
your 30-second warning so i'm going to
give you a couple of seconds to wrap up
otherwise i'm going to have to solve you
permission for proposals and also
highlight the matters in relation to the
height of the canopy thank you
thank you very much um members do we
have any questions for our parish
council
no in that case thank you for your
contribution
i'm sure it was out of your control but
please don't be late next time well yeah
thank you this is a one-off
too much okay
our next speakers will be uh miss rogers
and mr gesse i think i'm pronouncing
that right if you'd like to make your
way forward as soon as you're able to
um
kevin i made a mistake with a stopwatch
i've allowed 24 seconds over i will
allow you 24 seconds over your time as
well so you have three minutes and 24
seconds i'll give you a warning at three
minutes um otherwise when you're ready
it's over to you
so
first of all when you when you're
dressed if you wouldn't mind putting the
microphone on so it can be picked up and
can be heard um
secondly i understand that i've
apologized and i'm giving you a
commencer amount of time um you can use
as much or as little of that time as you
like
um
whenever you're ready before we start
okay
good evening so this is that application
is before you because ulster town
council considers the proposed canopy
causes harm to the greenbelt harm which
is not outweighed by the benefits your
professional case officer disagrees and
recommends that planning permission is
granted
so let's look at those harms and those
benefits
your officers report notes the following
national and local policies support
business and commercial development to
help grow the local economy
the same policies support the expansion
of an existing business particularly
where it'd be unreasonable to expect
that business to relocate
the current proposal will enhance the
existing business which cannot
reasonably relocate
the proposal due to limited canopy
height and tree screening and the
generally industrial nature of the
immediate and wider site has no adverse
impact on the landscape or the character
of the area the canopy causes no harm to
neighbour immunity there are no highway
concerns there are no issues regarding
flood risk drainage or ecology i remind
you those are the words of your case
officer not necessarily of me
in summary the only harm is that this is
inappropriate development in the
greenbelt
i set forward three key benefits the
first is economic almost all hand car
wash facilities today have a waterproof
canopy they are an essential part of the
business they provide cover for cars so
that they can be properly cleaned and
dried in wet weather it rains on over
100 days each year in the uk
they prevent cars from drying too
quickly and going streaky in hot and
sunny conditions and they protect staff
whilst they're working
prior to the installation of the canopy
the business was rarely breaking even
they had five employees not all
full-time
during the summer of 2020 once the
canopy was installed the business was
far more successful with an ability to
wash more cars to a higher standard i
believe something like 30 increase in
custom
the business is now much more
financially sound it provides a higher
quality of service to more people and
employs five full-time members of staff
the second benefit is to local people
who drive cars and want their cars
washed there are no other hand car wash
facilities in ulster or the immediate
locality
the business meets local demand and
minimizes the need for people to travel
the third key benefit is to the wider
community ulster car wash rents its site
from ulster rugby club the rugby club is
an extremely important local facility
with over 220 playing members and a
clubhouse for hire income to the club
continues to diminish and costs rise the
coveted pandemic has only made matters
worse for them
today the annual running costs of the
rugby club are in the region of 100 000
pounds a year and more than 20 of its
income derives from the car wash the
loss of the car wash would be hugely
detrimental to the rugby club and would
mean a reduction in local sporting and
other opportunities
planning requires you to undertake a
balancing exercise the harms against the
benefits the harm is harm only by reason
of inappropriateness i've set out
considerable economic and social
benefits arising from the proposal what
should be lost if the business are
forced to close a very real prospect
i hope you will agree that the benefits
outweigh the harms and therefore there
are very special circumstances which
were under grant approval
thank you very much three minutes and 12
seconds so we are good members do we
have any questions for our agent or the
applicant
you know
it's going to sound a bit silly but i've
never actually used one of these before
so uh the use of the canopy um if you
could just explain how the system
works so does a car come in it gets
washed goes under the canopy and
finished yeah and finished that
has that resulted in repeat business do
you tend to get the same customers back
week on week it's
all right
of course the canopy helps
where it's raining especially helps a
lot is more and more and more support
and we wash it in the drainage and we
finish in the canopy we don't want to
get even with employers now is they are
happy because they finish the car in the
rain
under the kanapi
and improving and is more professional
[Music]
okay
any other questions
no in that case thank you very much for
your patience and time and contribution
if you could give the table a quick wipe
with one of those anti-backs that would
be great
thank you very much um council cargill
as soon as you're able to if you want to
make your way forward
again i think you know the drill you
have five minutes 30 second warning i'm
not going to give you any more time
you were late after all
i'm sure out of your control so whenever
you're ready five minutes i'll give you
30 seconds warning it's over to you and
and thank you members for your
forbearance on this and again i will
apologize for our lateness but beyond
our control
thank you very much
um i'm not opposed to the operation of
the car wash at the site as it brings in
valuable income to the rugby club
especially after the traumatic time they
had with the illegal travel encampment
however
the original application 12-02756-4
was for just the car wash on the limited
footprint
subsequently we had application
14-015814 for a modular building for
welfare purposes this was refused as it
was considered that the proposal and i
quote
represented an inappropriate form of
development and representing a form of
encroachment harmful to the green belt
there were no very special circumstances
that would outweigh the application
and therefore contrary to section 13
other than nppf
it also noticed noted that the proposed
building was again and i quote of an
incongruous design and unacceptably
harmful to the rural and undeveloped
nature of the area
the modular building was installed
against officer advice and demonstrates
a disrespect for the planning system if
a 2.5 meter high modular building was
could considered inappropriate then a 4
meter high green canopy cannot be
acceptable
the canopy has been in location for a
while now
it offers no benefits to the immunity of
the staff and only for newly washed cars
as for streaky cars and that is
subjective
an attempt was made to grant lawful
development certificate for the canopy
under application 20
02908 lde and was duly dismissed
the offer comments were that this is
development under the legal definition
and it interferes with the actual
physical characteristics of the land
the canopy has been subject to an
enforcement action on the 22nd of june
2020 ref
200296
the fact that the canopy is
theoretically removable is a material in
this case as there's no reason to
presume otherwise it will be a permanent
feature of the car wash i hardly think
it's going to be taken down at weekends
the concrete of the posts in the grounds
and i quote the report must be
considered to have some degree of
permanence
next i wish to bring the to the
attention of the committee the
inappropriates of the development the
mpps states that inappropriate
development in the greenville bout is by
definition that definition harmful
i concur with the previous officer's
assessment in that reckoning it may be
considered by some that this canopy as
the lower end of the harm spectrum
however harm it is any development in
the green belt must demonstrate very
special circumstances to be approved
none have been demonstrated not to my
opinion
therefore policy cs10 applies which
states that the rural character of the
district will have been maintained and
enhanced the greenbelt will be protected
from inappropriate
development and that applies
we're all aware of the development tests
in cs10 an application must pass to
allow development in the greenbelt
needless to say none of the tests apply
here in fact none of the exceptions
include a car wash or canopy
we are regularly told that any
development of the greenbelt must have
public benefit to outweigh the harm i
cannot genuinely believe that a car wash
fits into that category can it and there
is another car wash in also incidentally
at the garage
for me when it comes to issues involving
green belt and special landscape areas
it should be the officer imposes tests
for the applicants to meet not me
the final point i wish to make is that
the canopy may be considered to be a
melody relatively minor addition to the
car wash but we've already seen
additions contrary to the officer's
views on this site so where will it stop
members that's one for you to answer
i respectfully request that the the
retrospective planning application
2101.0654 is refused for the following
reasons
inappropriate development in the
greenbelt inappropriate development in
the special landscape area no special
circumstances demonstrated harm to the
openness of the green belt contrary to
section 9 of the mvpf and cs10 of the
local plan thank you very much indeed
members
thank you very much cargo well within
your time members do we have any
questions for cancer cargill please
two council jennings first
it's just a really quick one i know that
you know all
all the sports clubs around that i
presume have you spoken to the rugby
club
do they support this
okay i haven't spoken to them
specifically about this i have been
speaking to them especially over the
travelers i absolutely don't doubt that
they will support this
because it brings in revenue to them
thank you i'll answer the simple
question cancer flaming next please
[Music]
okay so cargo and
we've heard a lot about how it
contributes to the rugby club um and
that it has uh contributes to local
amenities and whatever um what other
businesses does does do you think that
this actually helps within ulcers sort
of uh
officers area i mean
do the operatives live and work in also
where they contribute to local economy
or what what sort of situation is up
there
i'm not aware of that mr castle
what i'll say is that when it comes to
the immunity of the workers then we we
were sort of acquiesced on the modular
building
to help them out and support them in
that sense but again that was a contrary
to planning planning law i don't know
anymore um that they contribute to the
local economy uh i would ask that it's a
car wash that's all it is it's a car
wash it's not a great contributor we've
had the same number of employees i think
you've answered the question now council
cargill thank you
any other questions for council cargill
no in that case thank you for your
patience and your contribution again
please if you can avoid being late again
and thank you again in a very
uncomfortable position
members we now move to points of
clarification for our offices do we have
any questions and points clarification
to our offices
no in that case we moved to
uh councillor jeffrey's nurse mr
jeffress
no it's not counselor um
uh
just a point of clarification for
members before you
enter into debate members have heard a
good deal from the local ward member
about breaches of planning control and
enforcement action on this site as well
as historic planning applications
these are not material to the planning
merits of the application before members
and each application as you all know
must be determined on its merits
references were also made to parts of
the nppf in respective greenbelt
nppf 2021 that would be section 13 not
section 9 particularly paragraphs 147
onwards um i can confirm that the club
do support the application have written
to that effect
thank you very much um who would like to
kick us off counselor kendall
thank you chairman
right having looked at this uh my
understanding and i know it's in its
broadest sense my understanding of
greenbelt parties that prevent urban
sprawl i understand it has aspects to do
with openness and preserving openness of
the countryside however if this and if
this was a building i would be totally
against it in this location as i see it
it's three
steel poles stuck in the ground with the
canopy hung off it
as far as i'm concerned it's not harming
the openness of the green belt i'm happy
to propose that we grant this
application
thanks kendall thank you very much i'm
going to second that um
and you've pretty much said exactly what
i was going to say
the point of the green belt is to
prevent urban sprawl and is to preserve
the openness of it this is open on all
four sides had it been the modular
building and previously i think i would
be saying something very different it's
not a modular building it is a canopy
that is open on all sides i struggle to
justify that that damages the green belt
the openness of the green belt we have
got special circumstances that have been
preserved presented to us i think
they're valid on the main in the whole
um but i would also add that we have a
policy i think it's cs24 it might be 22
that says we should support the
expansion and growth of businesses in
their current location
that in itself i think is a special
circumstance to allow this in the
current location so i'm seconding
councillor uh kendall's proposal council
andrew serafin first yeah thank you
chair just a word i mean
i've used this facility for a number of
years
and i can see the benefit of that when
they do the valetin especially when it's
raining so i'll i'll definitely support
this application
good man thank you councillor adam i
think you indicated
um nothing for really further trout i'm
yeah i mean in full agreement with what
you even
said lovely stuff in that case unless
anyone else have anything to say we will
move to a vote and the proposal is to
grant in line with offers recommendation
show of hands please
close against
just the one no abstentions um therefore
uh
committee resolve to grant application
twenty one zero one zero six five full
in line with the officer's
recommendation there being no uh urgent
business it remains for me to thank
uh forgive me i believe there is one
asian business
there is yeah forgive me that is on
there um
okay forgive me
we do have some information on appeals
feedback so forgive me i'd miss that so
um who who are we going to lead on that
is that you do
over to you
thank you chair councillors this is just
a moment of appeal feedback which um
will be a returning item to this
committee whenever an appeal is received
chair councillors an appeal decision has
been received in respect of application
1900 731 ful the appeal was made by
countryside properties uk limited and
midland heart limited against the
council's decision to refuse permission
for the development of 50 affordable
houses at the development site at the
corner of waterloo road and wellington
road bidford on haven the refusal was
contrary to officer recommendation to
grant
the main issue at appeal was whether the
development would result in an
unacceptable loss of an employment site
within bidford on avon the inspector
found that the appeals site had not been
in
an employment use for at least 12 years
and was not subject to any land use
designations within adopted policy
documents for an employment use
accordingly the appeal was allowed the
inspector's decision was received on the
13th of august and council have advised
against a legal challenge of that
decision
if any counsellor wishes for further
information on this decision please
contact rob weeks the head of service
and this will be added to the next
agenda for the next scheduled counsellor
briefing on appeals thank you check
thank you very much david just for
members benefit um this is here at my
request um the idea is to help us make
better informed decisions so we can
understand how our decisions have been
taken forward through the inspectorate i
think it's important that we have it
there and that we understand it so
that's why it's there
this time there being no urgent business
it reminds me to thank you all including
our officers and everyone that's
contributed tonight for their time and
patience um i can declare the meeting
closed thank you very much
you